very interesting new poll shows that the
Maga movement is wildly unpopular really
unpopular one of the few things less
popular than Donald Trump himself is the
Maga movement just 24 of Americans
surveyed have positive views of the make
America great again movement in a new
National NBC News poll this is a very
interesting poll because it actually
surveys people about a number of other
issues so for example if you look at
black lives matter
um 40 percent negative
38 percent positive that's a net rating
of minus two now you might say wow BLM
is really unpopular in the United States
well it's far less unpopular than
everything else in the poll Joe Biden's
net rating the Democratic party's net
rating the Republican party's net rating
are all minus 10 meaning by a 10 point
margin they are seen more negatively
than positively more unpopular than
Biden the Democratic party and the
Republican party is Donald Trump Donald
Trump has a net rating of minus 19. 34
positive
53 negative and then even worse than
that is the Maga movement where only 24
of Americans see Maga positively and 45
negative that's minus 21 net
favorability now one of the really
interesting things strange concerning
about America things is that despite
Trump being very unpopular and Maga
being even more unpopular
Trump and his Mega movement are
currently easily the 2024 Republican
Front Runners and Trump if he becomes
the 2024 nominee
could easily win in 2024 the general
election he almost did win in 2020 even
though it was an 8 million vote margin
and a very solid popular vote win for
Joe Biden one of the biggest in fact uh
when you look at the electoral college
system that we have it didn't it would
not have taken that much of a shift in
just a handful of States three states
really uh to turn the election towards
Donald Trump now there's another
important question when you ask people
about favorability and opinions just
because moderate Republicans and
centrists for example don't like the
Maga label or everything that Maga
stands for doesn't mean they won't vote
for Trump anyway there is a huge
difference there's a canyon between I
don't like Trump and I'd vote for a
Democrat like Joe Biden those are two
very very different things Trump got 74
million votes in 2020. these were not
just the Fringe and extremists of the
Republican party we have to understand
this on the left yes naga's not
particularly well liked many Republicans
don't like Trump low favorability all of
it is true
but when you get 74 million votes it's
not just the Fringe extremists from your
party there were self-described
centrists who really didn't like Joe
Biden there were moderates there were so
on and so forth so it's very plausible
that if Trump makes the same failed
promises again I'll bring back jobs
we're gonna get two dollar a gallon gas
we're going to replace Obamacare with
something beautiful whatever promises
many of these people are going to fall
for it again even if it doesn't make a
damn bit of sense so Mega not popular
could still win in 2024